they are business people in Britain have
been campaigning for their country to
exit the European Union pan wats
complains that the EU is isolating
itself from World Trade its purports to
have 50 trade agreements but there was
tiny irrelevant states and so they're
stopping us from being able to get out
there and trade globally and that is so
important in today's globalised economy
and then there are business people like
Camille Miguel for whom a British exit
from the EU would be a nightmare
scenario there are lots of agreement
that we already are agreed and they will
reopen and have to renegotiate how long
it will take how damaging it will be to
the economy nobody can tell really
Jameel Miguel is a qualified engineer
and self-made man his company earns
around 150 million euros annual revenues
he supplies components to Daimler BMW
and other car makers in the EU and
oversees the European single market
saves his company money at the moment
we're selling to Germany France anywhere
in Europe like whistling in the UK if we
outside of the European market it will
be an export for export you've got a lot
of export paperwork we've got lots of
money tied up and we'll have to get
clearance in the forge we'll have to do
a lot of things that today we don't do
and what can is employees expect if
Britain decided to leave the EU the work
is that this machine come from Lithuania
Slovenia and Poland would they have to
apply for a visa we don't produce enough
engineers enough skilled people here in
ourselves so if these people will have
to go back home we will have a serious
problem we spend years of training
highly skilled highly motivated people
the part of the community here and there
if they won't be able to stay it's a big
problem pan wats also employs workers
from other EU countries but she doesn't
leave they'd be forced to leave the
country immediately if Britain let the
EU sweet quiz' koski recycles
electronics and sells the materials all
over the world all according to EU
regulations it's way too bureaucratic
for companies like mine compliance is a
massive issue for us and what is the
point in having legislation when 20th
member states are alive
travel differently Pam wats had to
invest over 2 million euros a new
machinery to comply with new EU
provisions competitors in the
Netherlands interpreted the same
provisions more liberally and now
they're producing cheaper and what's
appears to have wasted her money she
says small companies like hers are often
pushed aside by EU legislation we have
no access to Brussels and of course if
we did want to we'd have to be able to
employ a very expensive lobby company in
fact we enquired about that and the
starting fee just to get them on board
was ten thousand pounds we can't afford
that so it's fine for corporates they
have their lobbyists but little
companies like mine have newster say in
Europe at all none these two business
owners have two very different takes on
Britain's future one outside and one
inside the EU we had lots of concessions
as England because of the our currency
now that then our condition is best than
the rest of Europe so I think we could
carry on and develop that even further
to be the best best condition while we
are in there is a big world out there
there are lots of options we have China
India and the state south america even
Africa's growing Europe see only
continent not actually economically
growing at the moment what consequences
would a brexit herb for Britain's
economy that's the prize question and a
subject of fierce debate
you